erdoan nunca había estado tan cerca de
una derrota qué mal quilishrou un
economista social demócrata de 74 años
encabeza la mesa de los seis la
coalición de la misma cantidad de
partidos a la que los sondeos de opinión
dan una ligera ventaja que podría poner
fin a dos décadas de mandato verdoán su
nombre surgió tras una negociación que
acabó con años de una profunda división
de la oposición en Turquía apodado
Gandhi kemal por sus maneras suaves y su
hablar pausado es un antiguo servidor
público electo parlamentario en 2002 y
líder del principal partido de oposición
el chp en 2016 condenó el intento de
golpe de estado contra ardoán y Poco
después su convoy fue atacado en el
noreste del país en un atentado del que
salió ileso hoy no está dispuesto a ser
concesiones su oferta de campaña tiene
tres ejes retorno al sistema de gobierno
parlamentario independencia del poder
judicial y políticas económicas más
ortodoxas
no vamos a dejar la suerte de la
República turca en manos de una sola
persona y nadie aceptará la palabra de
una sola persona
el partido sea HP Ya sabe lo que es
derrotar a erdoan una alianza con el
nacionalista centrista igi derivó en las
inesperadas victorias en
estambulliancara en las elecciones
municipales de 2019
la alianza opositores colorida eso era
que el próximo parlamento sea variopinto
en cuanto a sus actores posesiones
ideológicas Y debates
y también obligará al sistema mismo
hacer más consensuado
la pérdida de popularidad de erdoan por
una inflación disparada y una muy
criticada respuesta inicial al terremoto
de febrero en la frontera con Siria
parecen inclinar el favor popular hacia
quilish
el actual gobierno en el poder ha estado
allí desde que tengo memoria Y
definitivamente es hora de cambiar se
necesita mejorar las cosas
también promete liberar a presos
políticos como el filántropo osman
cábala y el líder Turco celahatin de
mirtha